efectivamente un primer set en el que el
espanyol arrancó bastante bien pero
luego tuvo en el segundo un momento un
poco como de laguna como que iba pasando
en blanco con kasper que había comenzado
ese seria cuando tres games a 0 quien
estaba jugando mucho mejor cometiendo
menos errores y el leyendo mejor el
juego del español al español no se les
vio en ese segundo set muy rápido muy
rápido con con sus piernas no se le vio
tampoco pegarle un bien a la pelota en
realidad cometió muchísimos errores
incluso una una doble falta para cerrar
ese set para cerrar perdón uno de los
game así que se le vio bastante errático
al español pero luego finalmente logró
remontar y quedarse con esa segunda
manga y ya para la tercera rafael nadal
decidió es ser completamente expeditivo
e hizo que kasper después finalmente un
poco pensando antes en el fantasmagórico
gas pero en ese tercer set en donde no
pudo marcar un solo punto en todo caso
quedarse con ninguna en game terminó 60
y rafael nadal pues que levanta
finalmente esa copa de los mosqueteros 1
más aquí en parís momento histórico por
supuesto el más grande de todos los
tenistas sobre tierra batida y sobre
todo ahora viene a sumar ya son 22 grand
slams a su palmarés y ese la tenista
hombre que más grand slams ha ganado en
la historia de tenis